لذلك نحن محاطون بشاشات هناك كيف
نستمتع بأنفسنا ولكن كيف
سنشاهدها يتغير عامل الشكل
إلى الحجم والشكل وحتى
فكرة الحاجة إلى شاشة على الإطلاق تتطور
أعتقد أن أحد التغييرات الكبيرة التي أجريناها
سنرى خلال العقد القادم
أننا سنبدأ في إجراء محادثات ذكية
مع كائنات غير حية ،
هل ستكون على وحدة التحكم في الألعاب ، هل
ستكون في كل شيء سيكون في
كل شيء keikar ، شركة فرنسية
تعتقد أن نظام الترفيه الخاص بك في المستقبل
سيبدو مثل هذا ، إنه نظام صوتي لجهاز العرض
ونظام أمان مدمج
في نظام
تعتقد أنه قد يكون هناك يومًا واحدًا
يستبدل فيه جهاز التلفاز ، وأعتقد أنه يجب
استبدال التلفزيون بشيء لأنه
قديم جدًا كما تعلم أن الأمر كله يتعلق
بالتعلم و  محاولة أن تكون أفضل
لخدمتك بشكل أفضل بدلاً من أن تكون مجرد مساحة
فارغة كبيرة تعرف أن تحويل
أجهزة التلفزيون إلى شيء أكثر من مجرد
صندوق أسود يمثل تحديًا تتعامل معه الكثير من
الشركات.
شاشات king أكثر مرونة أو التخلص
منها تمامًا ، يقوم الآخرون بتصميم
شاشات لتندمج في هذه
اللوحة التي ليست خلفي ، إنها في الواقع تلفزيون
يطلق عليه الإطار وهو من صنع
Samsung الآن عندما يكون التلفزيون مغلقًا ،
توفر Samsung مئات القطع من  الفن الذي
يمكن عرضه ولكن يمكنك أيضًا إضافة الفن
الخاص بك ويمكنك حتى تغيير
لون الإطار
ولكن ماذا لو كان بإمكان شاشتك التحدث إليك بالفعل ، فإن
بعض أكبر التطورات
التي سنراها في الترفيه المنزلي
ستكون  سماعات الواقع الافتراضي التي
تأتي إلى المنزل ، سنحدث
فرقًا كبيرًا في
أنظمة الواقع المعزز ومن ثم أيضًا
الشخصيات الذكية المصطنعة التي
تبدأ في أن تصبح جزءًا من الألعاب والتجارب الأخرى ،
لذا ستتحدث
عنها كشخصية في إحدى
ألعابك  شيء
تشاهده بدلاً من القول إنك تعلم ، يا
تلفزيون ، اسحب مقطع الفيديو رقم ثلاثة ،
يمكنك فقط أن تقول يا سيدني ، ما
الذي تعتقد أننا يجب أن نشاهده بعد ذلك
ar يحتوي caracal على
بعض الاقتراحات وسيجري الاثنان
محادثة عندما تصبح هذه التقنيات
جيدة بما يكفي ، هل تتوقع يومًا
تختفي فيه الشاشات تمامًا
يشبه ما حدث في التلفاز الذي يقتل الراديو ،
أعتقد تمامًا مثل ARS سيحل محل بعض
الشاشات  ستبقى شاشات التطبيقات على
قيد الحياة وتتوقف هناك